ثبتت قوه الدعم السريه عبر صفحتها في
فيسبوك مقاطع فيديو قالت انها توثق
سيطرتها على مطار مروي شمال السودان اليوم
ويظهر في تسجيلات المصوره عناصر من قوه
الدعم يقفون امام احدى الطائرات في ساحه
المطار واخرون امام احدى البوابات
الرئيسيه
كما بثت قوات الدعم السريع لقطات على
موقعها على تويتر قالت انها لدخول عناصرها
الى مقر اقامه قائد القوات المسلحه عبد
الفتاح البرهان داخل مقر قياده هذه القوات
الله اكبر
حق البرهان
الاخوه المساكين احنا قاعدين في التراب
المخازن يوم واحد
يا سلام العربيات البرهانه زرقن
البرهان بادين
ومن جانب الاخر فنادق رسمي باسم الجيش
السوداني ما يتم تداوله عن الاستيلاء قوه
الدعم السريع على مقر القياده العامه
للجيش السوداني او بيت الضيافه او القصر
الجمهوري وقال ان القوات المسلحات سيطروا
تماما على جميع مقراتها واضاف ان من وصفها
ببعض الابواق الاعلاميه لمن وصفها
المتمرده تبث كثيرا من الاكاذيب لتضليل
الراي العام كما اكد ان الوضع في العاصمه
يشتمل على شبكات محدوده حول محيط القياده
العامه ووسط الخرطوم مشيرا الى تنفيذ
ضربات جويه ضد اهداف وصفها بالمعاديه والى
تنفيذ ضربات ضد اهداف اخرى واكد ان ذلك
سيستمر حتى تصفيه اخر جيب للمليشيا
المتمرده في العاصمه وفق وصفه كما اشار
الى ان ميليشيا الدعم سريع بدات باعمال
سلب ولهب متفرقه تحت تهديد لممتلك ات
المواطنين العزل